you know why you saw that in the news
because they want you to believe that
racism is a real problem it wasn't even
on the news so you're lying she just
said that it was a woman it was not only
underneath it went viral on Twitter
let's fact check now I said it was on
the news yeah
but you're saying why you saw it on the
news yeah that's why I saw it so you're
adding to it they share these stories
like George Floyd and like that afro
nonsense that you saw in the news in
order for you to believe that there's a
system that's holding you back it's not
and you saw here we're talking about
race hold on so the man went online and
was like I didn't get the job sat there
and didn't have it at this point when he
was picking chose to run that story
because it gives people like you a
reason to feel people like me exactly
people like you no they used to want to
give my mom free food in the market
because they didn't believe that white
woman could have three little kids and
have Pros
to give up food because it's the thing
that we're a little African children
that suffer these times we're quite
wealthy so for example okay